so Halloween's coming up which means one
thing BuzzFeed is going to put out some
stupid [__] articles you know what
I'm saying I found it the other day 31
Halloween costumes that are so clever
I'm kind of jealous I didn't think of
them first first of all too long of a
[__] headline there's going to be so
many Barbies and Kens that I'm I got to
stay in because I can't be seeing that
[__] I can't be seeing some fat Ken you
know or some like plump Barbie some
chick that thinks like she's getting
away with it when it's like they were
going to make the Amy Schumer Barbie
movie if they did okay but they
didn't you know so be Cru uh the [__]
the the bad lady in Ariel in the [__]
the the pink the the purple fat lady you
know what I'm talking
about look look at this I dude I the
worst Halloween costumes are are the
cute things are like the ones where
you're
like a [__] bird and you're attached
to somebody painted blue and you're like
look I'm chick cord on blue or whatever
the [__] you know or or or or you're in
a dress and it says Freud and you're
like I'm a frui and slip like I that
stuff is dude that kind of [__] is so
cringe and I'm just like oh nah hey ah
if Halloween is the thing where you get
creative if that's the day you get
creative just give it
up like here we go ghost Malone this is
one of them no no no just no
I mean a
bumblebee why is a bumblebee something
that you're
jealous I'm not even going to go there
pumpkin spice
girl I mean whatever you
know oh no be Yonce a be that says Yonce
on it I mean come on dude look at this I
just look at this dude this lady's
dressed up as a chicken with a bra and
money under the bra a chicken strip dude
I I just said the [__] chicken C on I
didn't even read this
yet a white
claw oh God and she's a crab with a
white
claw oh dude no this is the worst one
I've ever
seen this lady has a shirt that says
blessing on it and sunglasses and a hat
and a Overcoat it says a blessing in
disguise
dude
no my mom would be like o how funny no
dude a copy cat oh oh dude this has fuan
slip on
it this is
hilarious this has the actual one I was
like is so [__]
stupid it she's wearing a slip dress
that says Theo
psychos ego mom ID oh god dude I
mean a [__] a nun with a briefcase
and it's she's none of your business
dude oh my God put a [__] dildo in my
anus repeatedly this is just ABS
dude use one of those [__] the SNM
things where you're you're where I'm
tied up and it just
goes with a big dildo raming in my butt
dude sorry I know my dad listen to this
podcast but come on
man yo this makes me feel bad these
things here's another one a spice rack
and she's got just a bunch of the Spice
Girl dolls around her neck on a on a
wood plank a deviled
egg Beauty and the Beasty Boys oh I'll
[__] [__] all over
dude oh
dude a web server oh oh dude she's got
look and she blurred her face out cuz
she knows it's stupid she she's got a
dress with a bunch of spiderwebs on it
and she's holding uh a a uh uh like
cocktails on her on her tray like a
server a web server
dude fantasy football dude this guy is
wearing a patriot Jersey and has a a
wizard beard and a a a
staff
bro
Jon Snow White I will I'll start a whole
singing career dude I I can't this is so
insane bro are you you don't like these
right oh he's he's he's on he's on
another team he goes I mean no
dude oh a Dill
d oh like a d and a dill oh God
oh the friend zone dude are you kidding
me dude are you are you are you kidding
me the friend zone and they're dressed
up
like people who do construction and
they're together I guess I don't know it
doesn't
matter bro these get worse these are
unbelievable check this out a formal
apology dude she's got a nice dress on
and a sash that says apology if you have
to
write the word on
it hey just go as a witch hey just go as
a
ghost just go as the
president you know be Baba duuk for
[__] sake I'm got to keep
going oh God old mermaids and they're
they're mermaids and they get the saggy
tits
no oh this is crazy bro a fly swatter s
SW it's a SWAT guy with a
[__] a shirt that says SWAT with a FL
I'm jealous cuz that's a low maintenance
outfit that's pretty good that's what
I'm jealous
of oh dude the Adams Adam Adam Adams
Family so I don't even want to do it
it's an one guy's an atom at one
guy's I don't even get
it Hell on Wheels okay well we got to
give her a pass because she's a
paraplegic and she's the de and she's
the devil so good good job lady even
though you
know a zomie will the be with his be
really get some mileage with that Darth
Slater a
woman with a
d I don't I don't know you got to be a
mom for like 12 years to appreciate this
stuff oh my God